it's time now for CBS deals and this
morning convenience is the name of the
game and we are sharing some items that
might help make your day a bit brighter
and a bit easier too all at exclusive
discounts start shopping now scan the QR
code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more good morning
morning happy Earth Day we have some
appropriate products but we're starting
with something that I've actually been
loving for over a year now you've
actually used I use this three times a
week five minutes at a time before bed
this is the solo wave wand the deal is
incredible run to cbsdeals.com because
it flew out of here last time at home
facial device so easy to use you just
put it up against your skin it has red
light technology micro current warming
therapy that's my favorite part because
it kind of relaxes me before bed you
just turn the head place it to your skin
go upwards it's going to de-puff it's
going to give you an instant glow 33 off
99.99 today under a hundred dollars and
I love this I just throw it in my bag
anywhere I go I am taking this with me
so like for the morning yes so important
so easy to use my eyes everything it's
just I feel like I'm doing my due
diligence that I everything I can do
maintenance gas maintenance exactly this
is like keep it safe wrap sealer
environment friendly yes reusable bags
come in three different sizes there's a
couple different packages so head to
cbsdeals.com but starting at 17 of the
deal today up to 40 off for these food
safe bags BPA free PVC free they could
go in the dishwasher they could go in
the freezer which I love because I
always make soup and freeze half of it
leak proof which is great gusset on the
bottom so they stand up
saves so much room in the refrigerator
in the pantry I love these and again
you're helping the plant to plant it by
reading yeah I love it and this okay I
feel like these were made just for me
these are woolsies these are dryer balls
you put a little oil on the dryer ball
they are handmade New Zealand wool
smell them smells so good and this is
great because me and my son have
extremely sensitive skin and we can't
use anything amazing it comes with the
uh the different oil 25 off today we
can't use any fabric softener we can't
use the dryer sheets because it just
doesn't work with our skin now I can use
a good smelling dryer ball my clothes
are fresh they smell like oh I love that
and they cut dry thyme in half so
there's two different kits starting at
22.49 that's the deal today 25 off all
righty wow now here is some fun stuff I
know if you're if you have the bling
lover in your life you need a little
Glitz and Glam Genevieve jewelry I we're
both rocking the tennis bracelet yes we
are fabulous luxury beautiful jewelry
for Less that you'll start at 19.95
today go up to 98 so under 100 she has
all different something for everyone
truly earrings Rings bracelets the
necklaces this is a celebrity loved
brand lizzo Queen Latifah have been
wearing these on the red carpet I love
I'm never taking this off I mean how do
you that's such a deal such a deal up to
67 off the savings today it's incredible
and again I don't have to be afraid to
wear this I know it's that beautiful
handcrafted quality jewelry for less
it's amazing and gorgeous I mean gifting
I like Mother's Day there's a lot coming
up yeah I'm gonna have to leave it there
oh my gosh all right well Ashley thank
you so much of course of course
we partner with all of these companies
to get these deals so to buy anything
you saw today scan your QR code on your
screen or head on over to cbsdeals.com